Le chapitre 15 de Marc
Un enfant aimé
En frappant ces personnes-là
Dieu va joindre cette condamnation
Et par les mépris, par les mépris, par les dégoût, tout ce qui a été illustré, car Dieu est en train de punir même la méchanceté pratiquée contre les fils sur les fils de façon vicaire.
Et c'est ça, la nouvelle nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle
la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la nouvelle la
a aucun élément dans ce cosmos
est privé
d'une intention personnelle
pour plus
un personnel
qui soit
les éléments
c'est lui qui
gouverne
est toujours en train de vouloir
communiquer quelque chose
à nous
au travers
toutes ces choses
c'est un cosmos
qui est
propriété
d'un dieu
personnel
qui est activement
engagé dans sa gouvernance
et lorsque ces ténèbres sont rassemblés par
dieu lui-même
l'objectif de dieu c'est de
communiquer quelque chose
au travers
l'obscurcissement
du soleil
les astres sont en train
de jouer leur rôle
et c'est important de voir pourquoi la création
a été engagée
dans ses jugements
cosmique
c'est un jugement
qui
dont
la nature
contribue
à la compréhension du scénario
mais
dont la création est engagée
dans toute cette discussion
et dans toute cette question
des corruptions
humaines
si nous lisons ensemble
roman
chapitre
qui nous dit le suivant
de la création
dont l'homme
s'est mis
lui qui était le représentant de ces scénarios
c'est quoi
quel était le but de dieu avec la création
c'est les lieux des dieux
qui visait à communiquer l'amour des dieux
la grâce des dieux
la gloire des dieux
pour qui dieu développe une communion avec ses créatures qui ont été capables
créés avec la capacité de jouir d'une relation personnelle avec dieu
c'était de voir toutes les manifestations de la beauté des dieux dans la création
de la bonté des dieux dans la création et de profiter de toutes ces choses en agrandissant
sa reconnaissance et son adoration envers dieu à propos ou à partir de sa relation avec la création
la création sert comme un scénario ou les théâtres des dieux comme ont dit certains théologiens
qui vise à provoquer une relation entre l'homme et la création
dont les fruits ou les produits c'est l'approfondissement de notre relation vers dieu et de la glorification
la reconnaissance de la gloire des dieux au travers de la création
mais pourquoi elle a été rendue à la vanité car l'homme n'est plus en train de développer une relation vers la création
qui lui fasse exprimer
reconnaissance envers dieu l'homme est plutôt en train de s'approprier de la création pour son bénéfice propre
en s'éloignant et en oubliant dieu
donc la création
a tombe dans la vanité non car elle veut elle a perdu sa signification nous sommes en train de détruire la création
car nous sommes en train de nous approprier
de quelque chose qui appartiennent à dieu et donc elle crie elle soupire elle souffre des douleurs d'enfantement
et c'est pour ça qu'elle se manifeste
à plusieurs reprises comme jésus nous a dit dans son serment stratologique
avec des convulsions
les catastrophes naturelles nous rappelle que la nature n'apporte plus la provision les manifestations de la beauté des dieux de la bonté des dieux
des bons gré des bonnes volontés
pardon
et la réalité
comme
Jonathan Edwards a dit c'est que
pourquoi elle ne fait pas ça
c'est car elle ne nous supporte plus
elle a envie de nous vomir
nous utilisons
la provision des dieux qui nous vient au travers de la nature pour pécher contre ce même dieux
elle n'est plus en train de servir à son usage sa signification centrale
de provoquer gloire à dieu
et c'est pour ça qu'elle est particulièrement engagée ici
dans ces scénarios des jugements
la création gouvernée par dieu chaque atome gouverné par dieu
ont servi à ce but les dieux de manifester un scénario des jugements
les théâtres qui servaient à communiquer les paradis
la communion avec dieu dans un paradis
maintenant devient un scénario d'enfer
les ténèbres
les midis
et là nous sommes en train de voir
particulièrement quelque chose dont la bible nous montre avec plus de clarté
dieu
est représenté à plusieurs reprises dans la parole de dieu
comme bien
Nat nous a communiqué
dans l'ouverture avec
les textes qui nous montrent dieu
qui lui sa face
comme un signe des grâces
et la bible nous montre par exemple
en psaume 27 aussi que l'éternel est ma lumière et mon salut
c'est à dire que quand on pense à la lumière on est en train de penser à la présence des dieux
mais particulièrement la présence des dieux avec un égard favorable
par contraste je peux venir aussi
comme ténèbres
à plusieurs reprises dans la bible on voit que dieu communique sa sévérité
par des visitations aux hommes de dieu au travers des danses ténèbres
c'est comme ça qu'il a avancé à abraham
que les peuples d'israël allaient traverser 400 ans d'esclavage en égypte
il est venu comme des danses ténèbres
donc on voit ces deux en phase qui montrent déjà les contrastes
dans les monts sinai aussi
il vient comme des ténèbres
comme des ténèbres
mais
lorsqu'on pense à la lumière
ça vise à communiquer la sagesse des dieux
les saluts des dieux
la faveur des dieux
la sainteté des dieux
et les bris de la gloire des dieux
et quand on pense aux ténèbres
on pense plutôt à cette sévérité des dieux
qui concerne sa réponse à notre condition
mais il y a un concept encore plus particulier dans la parole des dieux
dont les termes techniques
pour les jours du jugement
le thème technique pour les jugements final
c'est les jours du seigneur
et quelle est la description biblique du jour du seigneur
donc si tous étaient dans les froid
même les romans
particulièrement les juifs devraient être dans les froid
pourquoi
ils ont par exemple en joël
les chapitres 1
verset 15
qui ne parle du jour du seigneur de cette manière
ah quel jour
quel jour
car les jours de l'éternel est proche
il vient comme un ravage
chapitre 2 verset 10
devant eux la terre tremble
les cieux sont ébranlés
les soleils et la lune s'obscourcissent
et les étoiles
retirent leur éclat
l'éternel fait entendre sa voix devant son armée
car son camp est immense
et l'exécuteur de sa parole est puissant
car les jours de l'éternel est grand
qui pourra les supporter
2 verset 30
je ferai paraître des prodiges dans les cieux et sur la terre
du sang du feu et des colonnes des fumées
le soleil s'échangera en ténèbres
et la lune en sang
avant l'arrivée du jour de l'éternel
de ces jours grands et terribles
alors quiconque invoquera le nom de l'éternel sera sauvé
les salus sera sur la montagne de Sion et à Jérusalem
comme a dit l'éternel et parmi les riche après que l'éternel appellera
en Amos on va trouver la même conception des ténèbres
dans les jours du seigneur et les jours de l'éternel
les jours de l'éternel n'est-il pas ténèbres et non lumières
n'est-il pas obscur et sans éclat
et dans les chapitres 8 verset 9 il dit le suivant
les prophètes Amos
en ces jours-là dit le seigneur l'éternel
je ferai coucher le soleil à midi
et j'obscurcisserai la terre en plein jour
je changerai vos fêtes en deuil
et tous vos chants en lamentations
je couvrirai des sacs tous les rangs
et je rendrai cheve toutes les têtes
je mettrai les pays dans les deuils
comme pour un fils unique
et sa fin sera comme un jour d'amertume
Sophonie chapitre 1 verset 14
les grands jours de l'éternel est proche
il est proche
il arrive en tout hâte
les jours de l'éternel
fait entendre sa voix
et l'héros pousse des cris amers
qui est l'héros qui pousse des cris amers
on verra bientôt
mais les jours est proche
de l'éternel est là
donc
c'est un jugement
qui a été doublement accompli
cosmique
qui pointe envers l'eschatologie finale
les grands jours du seigneur
ces jugements dont nous tous allons participer
mais qui a été anticipé
de façon unique
à la croix
l'aspect vicaire
ne se répète plus
c'est ça qui est en train de se passer avec les Christ
mais c'est intéressant
comment les Christ lui-même a confirmé
les caractéristiques du jour du seigneur
on a lu, on a médité ensemble dans les chapitres 13 des marques
verset 36
la description du grand jour du jugement
dans ces jours après cette détresse
le soleil s'obscourcira
la lune ne donnera plus sa lumière
les étoiles tomberont du ciel
et les puissances qui sont dans les cieux
alors on verra les fils de l'homme
venant sur les nouer
avec une grande puissance
et avec gloire
cette condamnation présente de Jésus à la croix
n'a pas eu accompli
tous ces signes
mais elle a été suffisamment similaire
dans ces contextes de tremblement des terres
dans ces contextes de ténèbres
pour nous rappeler
que ce qui était en train de se passer au calvaire
c'était une anticipation
de quelque chose
qui est encore à venir
pour ceux qui ne se trouvent pas en Christ
Jésus confirme non seulement
les jours du jugement
et ça c'est super important
car les jours du jugement
c'est la portée du scénario
quand une catastrophe se passe
nous sommes tous des êtres humains
et pour plus qu'on soit hypocrite
la majorité du temps
lorsqu'on sent l'effroi
d'une impression des jugements cosmiques
on commence tous à évaluer notre conscience
et la réalité c'est que
dans ces grands jours du jugement
ces danses nouées qui ont couvert
Jérusalem et les pays
seront en train de couvrir toute la planète
et tous les genoux fléchira
et nous tous allons participer à ces jugements
donc les scénarios
ils visent à montrer quel type de jugement a lieu
c'est un jugement des coupables
ça révèle quoi attendre comme résultat de ces scénarios
l'effroi de se voir devant les juges
avec la conviction
que nous sommes coupables
les ténèbres, les scénarios
visent non seulement à communiquer
les scénarios d'un jugement qui va mal
mais qui anticipe une condamnation certaine
donc ce qui est important pour nous de méditer
et c'est ça que Jésus va nous rappeler
c'est que non seulement les scénarios
sont caractérisés par les ténèbres
mais les ténèbres de scénarios avancent
la condamnation qui est aussi marquée par les ténèbres
ces trois heures que Jésus a vécues
c'est la même chose que Jésus avait avancé en Matthieu
à trois reprises décrivant l'enfer
comme les ténèbres
ceux qui seront lancés dans les ténèbres du dehors
où il y aura des pleurs et des grancements des dents
cette éternité à l'enfer, cette punition
a été communiquée en avance par les scénarios du jugement
donc une chose va avec l'autre
les scénarios sont en train de servir
et en train d'anticiper, en train de participer
de cette condamnation
et nous sommes encore en train de méditer
sur les moments du jugement en soi
c'est ça le but de ces scénarios
pendant trois heures
le jugement final a été anticipé
et nous sommes en train de voir
comment ces scénarios ont été établis par Dieu
Dieu est le juge souverain
qui est en train d'établir ces scénarios
c'est pas Satan qui a porté ces ténèbres
c'est Dieu lui-même qui est en train d'apporter ces ténèbres
car
Dieu n'a pas été absent à la croix
aussi comme Dieu ne sera jamais absent à l'enfer
c'est la privation de ces égards favorables de Dieu
et c'est la manifestation continue de ces mécontentements
et donc les silences de Jésus manifestent
pendant toute la crucifixion
et donc on pose cette question comment il a pu supporter
comment il a pu supporter la moquerie
comment il a pu supporter la violence
mais avant comment il a pu supporter les silences
sachant qu'il était innocent
pendant les trois jugements qu'il a traversés
qu'on a vu ensemble
les Sénédrants, Hérode et Pilate
et après le peuple aussi participant
avec leur votation entre Jésus et Barabbas
comment a pu Jésus garder les silences
et la réponse c'est que
pour plus ténébreux
qu'un jugement qui concernait la possibilité
de la pire des morts la crucifixion
la plus humiliante des morts la crucifixion
comment il a pu supporter tout ça
car il savait
qu'il sait qu'il attendait
c'était un scénario
qui ferait les théâtres
du pire jugement possible
sembler
un jeu d'enfant
comparé au scénario
qui Dieu était en train d'établir maintenant
à partir de ces danses ténèbres
Jésus a été transcendant
envers l'humiliation humaine
et toutes les terreurs de la possibilité de la croix
car il savait que ce qu'il attendait
les danses ténèbres
qui nous rappellent
donc Dieu a fait usage
de la méchanceté humaine
pour communiquer au travers
les jugements les plus injustes de l'histoire
pour communiquer au travers la croix
les scénarios de la croix
pour communiquer et anticiper
un scénario encore plus terrifiant
donc nous allons tous participer
si nous ne sommes pas un Christ
l'intention du Christ c'était
et l'intention des dieux est
et c'est pour ça qu'il est en train d'attester
la vraie identité de fils
l'objectif du Christ
c'est de nous délivrer de ses jugements
c'est pour ça qu'il a dû endurer ses ténèbres
c'est pour ça qu'il a dû traverser ses jugements
! car quiconque
quiconque invoquera les noms de l'Éternel
sera sauvé
les saluts sera sur la montagne des Sions
donc il nous faut méditer
sur notre participation
dans les jugements du Christ
Christ a été jugé
à cause de notre coupabilité
c'est notre jugement qu'il était en train de vivre
et si nous ne sommes pas un Christ
si nous n'envoquons pas les noms du Christ
ces jugements reposent encore sur nous
dans les grands jours du Seigneur
pour certains sera la délivrance
ce qui se trouve en Christ car il a déjà été jugé à notre place
et pour d'autres
c'est le même type de jugement qui est reposé
toutes ces ténèbres qui ont été condensées
et intensifiées sur Christ
seront diluées
pour toute l'éternité
envers tous les pécheurs
donc les scénarios manifestent
un jugement qui va finir mal
qui va communiquer
il va participer
les scénarios participent à l'anticipation de cette condamnation
et à la condamnation en elle-même
et c'est pour ça que Jésus n'était pas qui en train
de subir un jugement
il était en train de subir à une condamnation
donc on va un peu plus en avant
et on va aller verset 34 pour voir la deuxième vérité
les premiers cris du Christ
le grand cri du Christ
attestent une réprobation
d'ordre surnaturel et unique
c'est la réprobation des dieux qu'il était en train de vivre
! verset 34 d'abord
et à la 9e heure
donc c'est à dire 3 heures de l'après-midi
15 heures
Jésus s'écria d'une voix forte
pourquoi m'as-tu abandonné?
nous sommes devant l'une des phrases les plus mystérieuses
et la parole des dieux
avec ces paradoxes
qui nous pointent envers la double nature du Christ
en tant que Dieu
les Christ n'a été jamais
complètement séparés de Père
mais en tant que Messie
en ayant s'est vidé de sa gloire
une vraie séparation des dieux
un vrai abandon des dieux
en tant que notre représentant
nous n'allons jamais
trouver l'explication finale pour ces textes
mais ce que les textes visent à communiquer
est en train d'endurer
enrégé
une réprobation réelle
un abandon réel
de la part des dieux
donc après que ces 3 heures
des ténèbres
aient fini
soit arrivé à leur
accomplissement
Jésus a finalement rompu les silences
et il va rompre les silences
pour clarifier l'expérience
qu'il était en train de vivre
c'est la conclusion
quelque part de Jésus
de cette expérience qu'il avait vécue
dans ce qui concerne l'abandon des dieux envers lui
et c'est pour ça que c'est important pour nous
qu'il est en train de communiquer
qu'il n'a trouvé
les moindres réconforts
de la part des dieux
pendant ces 3 heures
on est à l'attente
que l'Epsomme 37 verset 6
accomplisse
il fera
la première
est en droit
comme le soleil à midi
après 6 temps des moqueries
après 6 temps des mépris
après 6 temps d'injustice
Dieu va intervenir et faire briller
la gloire du Fils
comme le soleil à midi
mais les contraires
se passent pendant 3 heures
Jésus dans l'attente
dans la recherche
en regardant
pour voir s'il arrivait à voir
luire sur lui
la face des dieux
favorables
les plaisirs du Père
et tout ce qu'il voit
qui lui couvrent
aucun réconfort
c'est ça l'angoisse
dont il avait anticipé
au jet de ses manies
l'essence du péché
les péchés à la racine
avant d'être une transgression
de la loi
un acte de désobéissance
envers ce qui dans notre conscience
même appointe
comme étant les correctes à faire
donc nos actes
et nos transgressions
elles exigent une punition
ne commencent pas
avec les actes
les problèmes de l'être humain
c'est sa relation
c'est avant d'être transgressions
appontés dans la Bible
comme impiété
impureté
indignité
incapable
de provoquer
à Dieu
un égard favorable
seulement capable
de provoquer
à Dieu
les dégoûts
l'abomination
notre vilité
est dégoûtante
répulsive
de celui
comme dit Abba Kuk
qui ont les yeux tellement purs
qu'il ne peut même contempler
les mâles
mal
qu'est-ce que nous provoquons
à cause de notre vilité
de notre laideur
nous provoquons
un dégoût
c'est pour ça qu'on a vu
que ce que Jésus avait avancé
ce double aspect de la coupe
de la colère de Dieu
le déversement de la colère de Dieu
mais en même temps
la manifestation de l'abomination
il s'est fait pécher à notre place
il était méprisable aux yeux des dieux
tous ces mépris
que les hommes ont manifesté
envers les Christ
on peut enlever
on peut élever à l'infini
de comment Dieu
a regardé Jésus
car il était couvert
par la vilité
des pires pécheurs
de toute l'histoire de l'humanité
donc là
on est devant un Christ
qui cherche un réconfort
et dans ses cris
ce qu'il était en train de vivre
c'est qu'il n'a pas vu
luire sur lui
la face de son père
pendant ces moments
des trois heures de mépris
des ténèbres
il n'a qu'é provoqué en Dieu
les dégoûts
l'indignation
la rage
c'est
c'est ces visages là
qu'il a vu de la part des dieux
si les soleils
les ténèbres communiquent
les dégoûts des dieux
car il était couvert
par nos ténèbres
et cela nous a éclairé par Paul
en Galate
et en Corinthiens
où il nous dit
Christ nous a racheté de la malédiction
en étant devenu
malédiction pour nous
car il est écrit
maudit quiconque est pendu au bois
et 2ème Corinthiens
5,21 nous dit
celui qui n'a point connu les péchés
il a fait devenir péché pour nous
afin que nous devenions
justice des dieux
c'est ça que Jésus entend vivre
la croix
c'est
les soleils
éclipsés
par les ténèbres
les pères
essayent de regarder
la justice du fils
mais il est couvert
de notre ténèbres
les fils
essayent
de contempler
les réconforts
du visage
du soleil
du père
mais comme il est couvert
par nos ténèbres
il ne voit
qu'est la manifestation
de l'indignation
de Dieu
du dégoût
car
c'est comme ça
que tous les êtres humains
sont vus par Dieu
dans leurs conditions
de péché
c'est la vérité
pour plus que vous
voudriez
penser différemment
ça c'est la vérité biblique
je ne suis pas en train de présenter mon avis
et si nous n'avons pas
une conscience de notre
de notre laideur
c'est car
vous n'avez jamais considéré
le niveau de la dignité de Dieu
et de la sainteté de Dieu
combien aimable
Dieu est
c'est comparable
à sa dignité
pour avoir accès
à sa présence
à la communion
avec lui
à sa gloire
aucun être humain
ne peut contempler
la gloire de Dieu
et se sentir digne
de son amour
nous connaissons tous
lorsqu'on n'est pas dans l'hypocrisie
que nous aimons les plus
que nous ne pouvons pas afficher
nos pensées
notre laideur
nous péchons
et nous transgressons
car nous sommes indignes
nous sommes ténèbres
et la réalité c'est que
Jésus
a pris notre indignité
et a supporté
cet abandon de Dieu
et c'est intéressant
car le texte
que quand même
après ces grands cris
c'est un méga cri
c'était un cri
vraiment
convaincant
étonnant
car normalement
celui qui a été
qui avait traversé
les processus de crucifixion
n'avait plus de force
la force
ne faisait que des séphanées
et Jésus est en train
pour pousser ces grands cris
et dire
mon Dieu mon Dieu
pourquoi m'as-tu abandonné ?
et c'est intéressant
car l'incrédulité
elle continue
les versets 35 et 36
nous montrent
que quelques-uns
de ceux qui étaient là
l'ayant entendu
voici qu'il appelle Elie
et l'un d'eux
courut remplir une éponge
et des vinagre
et l'ayant fixé un roseau
il lui donnait à boire
en disant
laissez
voyons
si Elie
reviendra descendre
qu'est-ce qui c'était
une procédure légitime
des compassions
les commentaristes
sont divisés
ou
ils étaient dans les doutes
de ce que Jésus avait dit
difficile
car c'était un grand cri
la plus grande probabilité
c'était qu'ils étaient
en train de tordre
les paroles du Christ
pour continuer dans leur idolâtrie
et ne pas reconnaître
ce que Jésus était en train de vivre
à la croix
et ils continuent donc
dans leur moquerie
en voulant que Jésus
ait suffisamment
des temps
et des vies prolongées
pour que peut-être
leur idolâtrie s'accomplisse
leur vision du Christ s'accomplisse
et ils sont
ou seront dans l'attente
de cet accomplissement
jusqu'aujourd'hui
c'est riant
pourquoi ?
car peu importe qu'elles soient
vos visions particulières
à propos du Christ
c'est la vision des dieux
qui compte
et la réalité
c'est que Jésus
par cet acte
de boire
les vents qui lui a été présentés
il a rajouté
des clartés
envers la signification
de ce que s'est passé
à ce moment
il a bu
jusqu'à la dernière goutte
la coupe de la colère des dieux
de ces vents mélangés
des colères dont la Bible nous parle
pour clarifier encore plus
c'est ça qui est en train
de s'accomplir
n'attendez plus Elie
et en bouvant
il a pu dire juste ensuite
t'es t'es l'estai
tout est accompli
donc il a voulu communiquer vraiment
cette coupe de colère
qu'il était en train de boire
qu'il avait bu pendant ces trois heures
et que maintenant il a illustré
l'accomplissement de ce mépris
c'est la première fois
que Jésus dans toute sa vie
enregistrée dans les écritures
ne fait pas référence
à Dieu
comme les Pères
c'est la seule fois dans la Bible
où Jésus va faire référence à Dieu
avec cette conception d'un Dieu
qui n'est pas les Pères
de tous les êtres humains
mais de Dieu
juge
de Dieu
créateur
et seulement cette conviction
mon Dieu
mon Dieu atteste
la présence des dieux au calvaire
comme la présence des dieux
sera
le Dieu omniprésent qu'il est
dans l'éternité de l'enfer
l'infliction de la peine
n'est pas
tâche de Satan
Satan
sera un comme les êtres humains
sous la position constante
de ses regards mécontents
d'abomination des dieux
envers toutes les créatures rebelles
mais c'est unique
cet abandon du Christ
car
Jésus
a un arrière-plan
inédit
nous
dès notre naissance
on n'a jamais connu
la communion
envers Dieu
jusqu'au moment
de notre conversion
par la grâce des dieux
on avait
une idée des dieux
on profitait
de cette grâce des dieux
qui s'appelle patience
dont nous pouvons encore
contempler et jouir
de la bénédiction des dieux
dans cette période de patience
qui n'est cerquée à nous donner
l'opportunité
de nous répentir
et nous convertir
mais on n'a jamais
profité
de la communion
personnelle
envers Dieu
avant notre conversion
Jésus son arrière-plan
est complètement opposé
il est la
deuxième personne
de la trinité
l'aimé des dieux
pendant toute l'éternité
et lorsqu'il
goûte
et la question est
mais comment trois heures
d'abandon
peuvent payer
une éternité
de souffrance
car la qualité
l'intensité
de cet abandon
c'était d'un ordre
qui pourrait couvrir
un nombre infini
d'enfer
Jésus
vis-à-vis
à l'arrière-plan
de sa communion trinitaire
c'était l'abandon
suprême
aussi vis-à-vis
à sa doiture
parfaite
et innocence
d'être coupé
de la présence
des dieux
de ne pas
avoir
vu sa lumière
sa dignité
jouir
éclater
c'est la première fois
et en même temps
à cause de cette relation personnelle
du père envers les fils
les fils a toujours été
les plaisirs
suprêmes
du père
ces termes
importants nous tous cherchons
l'approbation
et les pires
c'est que nous cherchons
l'approbation des personnes
qui sont viles
au lieu de chercher
!
l'approbation
et la réalité
c'est que cette
approbation
des dieux
du christ
des dieux envers christ
!
voici mon fils bien-aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute mon affection
Jésus n'a jamais goûté
les moindres égards
de la part du père
qui n'est communiqué
qu'est du plaisir
et du plein plaisir
il n'y a pas un seul moment
dans nos vies
avant notre conversion
où nous puissions
imaginer
regarder
la face des dieux
et voir que dieu a du plaisir
dans nos vies
nous sommes morts
dans nos péchés
le coeur de l'homme
est désespérément corrompu
ça c'est notre condition
organiste
mais
c'est inédit aussi
non seulement à cause
de l'arrière-plan
du fils
mais c'est inédit aussi
à cause
de la condensation
de la laideur
de la vilité
qui a été condensée
et qui a reposé
sur les fils
c'est-à-dire
c'est une chose
de payer les prix
d'une seule personne
et nous
nous avons cette tendance
de nous comparer
on est comme
on a la lumière
et on a les ténèbres
donc
la distinction
selon la parole de dieu
est qualificatif
c'est clair
c'est pas quantitatif
on est
on n'est pas en train
quand on est parlé
c'est un peu moins sombre
un peu plus clair
etc
pourquoi
car la comparaison
c'est avec la dignité
des dieux
et dieu est lumière
ok
et nous nous sommes tous ténèbres
dans les ténèbres
nous puerons nous comparer
et la réalité c'est que notre nature
est également corrompue
les potentiels pour les mâles
pour les mâles chez l'être humain
elle est même
d'aller jusqu'à Hitler
nous tous
et plus on donne
et plus la grâce de dieu ne freine pas
notre méchanceté
et plus on donne
possibilité à notre chair de se manifester
et plus vile on devient
et plus dégoûtant on devient
nous sommes une race qui doit
se maîtriser
se contrôler
nous avons besoin
de nous protéger les uns des autres
nous avons la capacité de créer des guerres mondiales
nous avons développé les tortures
une croix
voilà la laideur suprême de l'homme
manifester à la croix
c'est mépris des dieux envers nous
car
la condensation de la laideur de tous les êtres humains
a reposé sur les Christ
et car il s'est revêtis
de cette manière inédite
de la laideur de tous les êtres humains au long de l'histoire
qui seraient sauvés en Christ
Dieu lui regardait à ce moment
comme plus abominable que les pires des athées
les plus abominables que les pires des pédophiles
plus abominables
qu'une légion de Hitler
plus abominables que les persécuteurs de l'église
plus abominables que les malfaiteurs à droite et à gauche
!
les pères
contemplaient
les fils
et voyaient la laideur
condensée
de tous les êtres humains
les plus vils et méchants
de toute l'histoire
et quel était le but de Dieu
en faisant cela
s'est revêtu
de notre laideur
de notre méchanceté
de notre vilité
pourquoi?
pour pouvoir
supporter un abandon
une réprobation
qui était la nôtre
l'objectif des dieux
c'était de traiter de cette manière
de regarder son enfant de cette manière
pour que
en ayant
couvert les Christ
de notre vilité
nous puissions être couverts
de sa dignité
c'est-à-dire que
la merveille de l'évangile
ne peut pas se trouver
dans la cachette
de notre vilité
l'église elle est très vite
pour convaincre les personnes qu'elles n'ont pas de coupabilité
Dieu abomine les péchés
mais aime les pécheurs
Dieu abomine les pécheurs
aussi que les péchés
et la preuve
c'est la manière dont Christ a vécu ces trois heures
cette abomination
celui qui n'a été jamais séparé du Père
pourquoi m'as-tu abandonné?
imaginez les fils
contemplant les cieux
cherchant
qu'il a toujours eu
et ne voyant que les ténèbres
et les Pères
cherchant les fils derrière ces ténèbres
et ne voyant que notre vilité
quel moment désespéré
et la suite c'est que
même si les ténèbres étaient entre
le soleil
et l'étoile du matin
les soleils
étaient en train
d'agrandir son plaisir dans cette oeuvre
et l'étoile du matin
était en train de faire briller encore plus
sa dignité
au travers son humiliation
ça veut dire que
la dignité du Christ
qui nous est crédité
car
a été crédité à lui
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
Dieu
essaie de trouver en nous
nos ténèbres
mais car nous sommes couverts du Christ
il nous va qu'er la lumière de l'étoile du matin
par la première fois
nous pouvons nous présenter devant Dieu
avec l'assurance
que l'approbation des dieux envers nous est complète
nous nous présentons couverts du Christ
et Dieu cherche des ténèbres en nous et ne trouve pas
car nous sommes revêtus du Christ
c'est comme ça que Dieu nous voit
et même si nous voyons encore la réalité des ténèbres pendant ces processus de sanctification
notre position devant Dieu est telle
que cette oeuvre est tellement assurée
tellement glorieuse
qui brille des gloires en gloire jusqu'à devenir jour parfait
nous sommes enfin des lumières
et notre lumière
c'est à dire que nous avons
toute l'approbation des dieux sur nous
si nous sommes en Christ
et dans la réalité
nous plaisons progressivement à Dieu
des façons effectives
les plus
on marche dans la résurrection
spirituelle
que nous avons en Christ
cet abandon vicaire ne va plus s'éreptir
ce qui a été condensé
en termes d'indignation sur les fils
va être dilué sur chaque être humain pendant toute l'éternité
tous ceux qui ne sont pas en Christ
de considérer que l'enfer
est un lieu qui doit être compris
par
les manques
absolus et éternels
des réconforts de la part des dieux
de regarder Dieu
qui est
c'est l'enfer
Dieu nous regardant
comme abominable à toujours
mais c'est super de considérer que car Jésus a vécu
la condensation de ses jugements
de cette condamnation
nous pouvons aujourd'hui
!
avec
l'assurance
que nous avons son approbation
si nous sommes un Christ
nous allons nous arrêter ici
les jugements
les scénarios de jugement
que Jésus a vécu à notre place
et en considérant
l'abomination qu'il a pris sur lui
la parole va nous dire
qu'on a eu des réponses différentes
à cette manifestation
à cette intervention des dieux
certains sont sortis encore plus
convaincus de leurs péchés
mais ont resté dans les crudités
frappant leur patrine
sachant que ces jugements les attendaient
certains ont aussi répondu favorablement
au message de l'évangile
et les plus intéressants c'est que
les plus vils de scénario
c'était ceux qui ont
contemplé les saluts
pour qui ça nous donne l'histoire à tous
c'était les centeniers
responsables de l'exécution
et les voleurs à la croix
!
l'indignité de ces hommes
a été complètement
en lumière
car ils se sont appropriés par la foi
et la dignité de Christ